Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Many of you have surely heard the word Animoji,
which refers to these emoji figures that are
animated in real time and react to our facial
gestures.
This is implemented in the new iPhone X phones,
however, to accomplish this, it uses a dot
projector get a good enough understanding
of the geometry of the human face.
So, how about a technique that doesn't need
any specialized gear, takes not even a video
of you, but one photograph as an input, and
creates a digital avatar of us that can be
animated in real time.
Well, sign me up!
Have a look at these incredible results.
As you can see, the final result also includes
secondary components like eyes, teeth, tongue,
and gum.
Now, these avatars don't have to be fully
photorealistic, but have to capture the appearance
and gestures of the user well enough so they
can be used in video games or any telepresence
application where a set of users interact
in a virtual world.
As opposed to many prior works, the hair is
not reconstructed strand by strand, because
doing this in real time is not feasible.
Also, note that the information we are given
is highly incomplete, because the backside
of the head is not captured, but these characters
also have a quite appropriate looking hairstyle
there.
So, how is this even possible?
Well, first, the input image is segmented
into the face part and the hair part.
Then, the hair part is run through a neural
network that tries to extract attributes like
length, spikiness, are there hair buns, is
there a ponytail, where the hairline is, and
more.
This is an extremely deep neural network with
over 50 layers and it took 40 thousand images
of different hairstyles to train.
Now, since it is highly unlikely that the
input photo shows someone with a hairstyle
that was never ever worn by anyone else, we
can look into a big dataset of already existing
hairstyles and choose the closest one that
fits the attributes extracted by the neural
network.
Such a smart idea, loving it.
You can see how well this works in practice,
and in the next step, the movement and appearance
of the final hair geometry can be computed
in real time through a novel polygonal strip
representation.
The technique also supports retargeting, which
means that our gestures can be transferred
to different characters.
The framework is also very robust to different
lighting conditions, which means that a differently
lit photograph will lead to very similar outputs.
The same applies for expressions.
This is one of those highly desirable details
that makes or breaks the usability of a new
technique in production environments, and
this one passed with flying colors.
In these comparisons, you can also see that
the quality of the results also smokes the
competition.
A variant of the technology can be downloaded
through the link in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!